in case you confused it with Los Angeles
Tanzania senator the hall
come on tighten it up tighten what up
there's only one way to do single final
that I'm aware of and this is a very
good representation of it
he passed before you were born but you
had a father what was his name
Apollo oh yeah well I guess that works
too especially since you need a dramatic
answer to this question that also
describes the title character who wasn't
dead in case you can fuse it with
Tijuana North Korea since this movie is
already over two hours do we really need
to see Adonis's entire ascent up the
stairs oh shoot this fight on film and
it's so pristine after 40 years
what an incredible live broadcast that
must have been also you know it's a
rocky movie when they use footage from a
previous rocky movie to inflate the
runtime wait a minute mix the original
Rocky movie not all Rocky movie and
destroyed by my own logic you know I
ain't training nobody training you I'm
gonna make sure about that why he's
clearly in shape and can fight and him
being Apollo's son will be a marketing
and money-making bonanza for everyone
involved even if he didn't do well well
I got put up for five seconds of this
guy's boxing stats and six seconds of
this guy's boxing stats also so begins a
slew of Nike product placement with this
dude Creed's undershirt let's guy with a
Nike swoosh and this dude I don't knock
you up myself in case you confused it
with you know what this movie does this
a lot
here's five cents mainly because this
movie is gonna have so few and that
drives me crazy I want to talk to you
about training me true stuff no more
because then we get rocky fine so how'd
you beat him time time you know takes
everybody undefeated wait are you
talking about the time you beat him in
Rocky - are you talking about the time
when Drago killed him in the ring I
could argue neither of those things had
anything to do with time and especially
not in the way you just said it in Rocky
- I guess you could argue that since
you've knocked each other down and the
15th and you were the only one to get up
before the count that time one there but
this is a seriously confusing way to
answer the question no this thing sure
let's give a guy who's been hit in the
head more times than a whack Amole a
guessing game no really I'm sure he can
work it out during the hundred and
thirty-five minute run time don't need
to get to the story or anything who
wanted their fight you did you see how
I'm satisfying the answer is why
couldn't this just be kept a secret the
last shot of Rocky 3 is one of the most
magnificent cop-outs ever but I always
thought the point was did it really
matter
having five cents for this with a
trainer whose father guided icons of the
past
Jesus everybody needs a family
connection in this movie also this is
the last we'll see of wood Harris in
this movie look if you're gonna give us
wood give us one that lasts for a while
not the six hour wood but maybe a good
15 minutes of wood wood do movies idea
of character development is literally
typing it out on the screen
look this is tremendously convenient for
him to see this poster and it's Thursday
but does he really do a double-take
because he thinks it's the girl from his
apartment the poster looks nothing like
the woman he scolded earlier so we that
was it he came by and stalked her and
didn't say anything cool story man yeah
that's it good as if it were baked into
the formula every Rocky movie goes
through this fighter once a guy to train
him but the trainer doesn't want to face
always too dangerous the trainer is
always too old to move this along I
would have accepted a plotline where
Apollo somehow made rocky promised that
if Drago killed him rocky would train
his illegitimate son if he ever came
knocking and we would have sinned and
out of that but it'd still be more fun
than the Sun not gonna train you okay
I'll train you nonsense but if you lose
that there breaks what cloud old man
doesn't understand how new stuff works
cliche so it's like your version of
smirk also this will be the last time we
hear of John so I'm glad we took a
journey down that road think we're
better people now probably need to get
Johnny Brenda's to update their posters
then since it has Bianca listed as being
there on Thursdays cool yes we all
remember that great moment in the
original rocky when he chased after
chickens to build up his speed and
hand-eye coordination
after that it was catching a fly with
chopsticks classic Rocky running jumping
Rove push-ups pull-ups
[Music]
shoes well now we know that B and
Michael B Jordan doesn't stand for
Brando I'm not saying that for his
acting skills but that Brando impression
Adonis willingly touches Pauly's Swank
magazine they must have decided to leave
out the subplot where Adonis contracts a
multitude of STDs and a major staph
infection after sleeping in the unwashed
Polly bed linens rocky doesn't believe
in pulled hammies at least he's not
making Donny drink for raw eggs or
whatever the he did in that first movie
you know I think they're the toughest
guys in the world a lot of ways maybe
it's in the water I don't know this
might explain why they're professional
sports stadiums come included with jails
this movie montage is so hard it's a
survivor song or two away from being
Rocky for just before Creed two decided
to be rocky for how long the regulate
one is oh come on you know the best way
not to bring attention to yourself don't
go to Philadelphia and have Rocky Balboa
train you I'm freaking out okay I'm
freaking out right now I got to get some
of all the things to show that Donnie is
nervous about his first big fight this
is what you pick classy dialogue and in
front of his girlfriend no less it's
about you it's all about you
as long as sly gets his allotted amount
of screen time that is this movie's good
formulaic because boxing movies have
been done to death but I highly welcome
the unbroken shot of this fight most
directors would want to edit on every
punch or two so that the editing does
their job for the but here we even see
Donnie's I get bloody at a piece of
Hollywood magic that is so good I'm
removing three cents I see Adonis is
taking the rocky approach of the best
defenses to get punched a ton in the
face and still come out a winner
technique Oh a bedroom right hang on
your friends couch is so overrated in
such a bad form tell me
I understand Donnie wanting to make a
name for himself but did he really think
he'd be able to keep the secret that
he's Apollo's son from everybody
remember this is a fight involving the
number four light heavyweight in the
world a fighter trained by Rocky Balboa
himself and big enough to promote with
full-size banners any boxing rider would
have figured this out just like Pete did
earlier
welcome to PTI boys and girls Tony
Kornheiser a little history on Apollo
Creed I certainly have him right up
there as maybe the best of all time it's
a little weird when they put real sports
talk shows in these fictional movies
they obviously talk about real life
sports stars like LeBron James and Tiger
Woods so Apollo Creed is maybe the best
fighter of all time is a statement that
suggests Sugar Ray Robinson Muhammad Ali
Joe Lewis and others must have never
fought in this world I found this
so earlier Ricky Conlan punched Danny
wheeler and broke his jaw before the
fight so the fight was cancelled and
Ricky got sued for it now the movie is
going to say that Donny is the only
boxer Ricky can get good money fighting
like there aren't any other willing and
famous boxers the public would pay tons
of money to see it's also pretty
hilarious that Apollo Creed's son is
dominating the news cycle as if people
deeply care about boxing enough in 2015
to put it on the front page
use 50 nano down there and with this
Purina find that makes you 60 nano now
nobody needs to know these fights were
in some hole in the wall but they will
it's 2015
not 1976 this is about his unbelievable
there's no one knowing he was Apollo
Creed son up until now can't do it it's
not my name but I want to make it on my
own merit anyway it's so making it on my
own thing it's very noble and all but he
kind of already has made it on his own
and because of that everyone discovered
who he was so the quicker this avenue of
the film is retired the quicker the film
gets to create Jesus did we really need
the rocky gets cancer portion of this
movie I know he's old and everything but
can we not move this thing along
it adds seven minutes to this movie
right when it was picking up momentum
this feels like a scene they gave
Sylvester Stallone because they felt
like they owed him one even though he
was the main character and six other
goddamn Rocky movies this is called
Creed right man forget about I the tiger
Donnie has eyes of an eagle to see these
brochures in Rocky's jacket pocket and
as Donnie seemed like the meddling type
also father figure tries to hide results
of cancer diagnosis but pamphlets are
found in the pockets of his jacket
cliche Leena hey good-lookin baby cream
call me I know this movie sets up Donnie
as a kid with a major chip on his
shoulder and despite living in the lap
of luxury for more than a decade he
still has this driving anger and need
for respect but come on this is
manufactured tension when we should
already be getting to the pre title
fight montage with footage from all six
other Rocky movies for some reason why
does every single movie feel like it has
to have a dramatic turning point like
this would it have mattered if Adonis
and rocky stayed tight the whole film it
would have definitely saved us from
having to suffer through soap opera
scenes like this it's taken a toll you
rocki ramblings would you meet you just
have a little ego contest rocky soon oh
that's why you got in a fight with tone
Trump Rocky's sick
ma'am I take back everything I said yeah
also Adonis won't back down one bit from
the Creed name but throws the cancer
card around immediately when he realized
his booty might be taken off the table
what I look like letting you train me
while you sit around and die I had no
idea the seventh movie in a popular
boxing series would turn it in terms of
endearment but here we are typical wacky
montage now with a hundred percent more
cancer scenes also look I know people
might snooze at him watching film and
looking for the weaknesses and strengths
of his opponent but surely boxing is
more than just sparring running doing
jumping rope hitting a speed bag and
getting updates on Rocky's chemotherapy
I think we see one shot of them looking
at an iPad in this movie good thing
Rocky was in that window to see all this
because this scene wasn't pink cheesy
enough I'll be honest there what a
surprise that no one who has ever seen a
film before Oh like that yeah support
Rocky has the unreasonable request that
if you're in a sexual relationship with
Tessa Thompson and/or Michael B Jordan
you somehow could resist having sex with
them just because you have the biggest
fight of your life coming up and I'm
sorry rocky but we know damn well that
this is a vortex of hotness that will
wait for no boxing match look I'm not
saying an unbroken shot in and of itself
deserves a sin off the way it builds
tension from the quietness of this room
to the noise of the arena is god damn
spectacular and the fact that the camera
spins around about six times navigating
a difficult path is worth removing
another Center counterpoint this
tracking shot is very cool but also
makes the movie feel more like a sequel
to Snake Eyes than rocky so soon counter
agrees this is a watch it's a wash
here's the case of an unbroken shot that
should have been broken I love how this
fight is set up in every way except for
the fact that Donnie and Conlon haven't
built up a good healthy hate for each
other other than a brief press
conference there is no reason to want
Donnie to win other than simply he's the
main character the way we got here was
kind of a mess with komlin only becoming
the primary villain 38 minutes ago and a
lot of that time was spent on The Fault
in Our Stars movie rightfully reminds us
who the this is because it's quite
possible at least 80% of the audience
had forgotten that Skillman what chance
does the young American have well he's
got the name that's why he's here
tonight Max Kellerman now has appeared
in two Rocky movies and that feels like
a sin this is the main event 12 rounds
of boxing for the light weight does the
ring announcers reverb clear up once it
gets broadcast through a television nice
show us boy sous-vided a game e25 hmmm
that's a weird insult since Apollo would
be like 67 and in no shape to fight they
don't know well you've been through and
they sure don't know what we've been
through good
didn't think pre could make it this long
the announcers have nothing else to talk
about other than Adonis wasn't expected
to last more than around Kellerman and
Lampley can't call a fake fight very
well at all I assure you that even
though this punch is in slow motion
Donnie gets knocked down to the canvas
that lasts way longer than 10 seconds he
has time to think about his entire life
and choice scenes from The Thin Red Line
while he lies on the canvas somewhere
Jack Dempsey is rolling in his grave
how many think is poor is it really in
your fighter's best interest to tell
them the answer when his eye is
completely swollen shut and he could end
up getting destroyed because of it
besides does this finger hold her up her
guy not see there's no way he could see
those fingers King lashes look like a
zipper track for his eyelids I'm willing
to go across this room you're not this
bitch down
can you do it sure you can do it I mean
he hasn't been able to do it with two
functioning eyes this whole match but
sure you can do it with only one eye now
they're trading shots accept every
single person who has ever seen a Rocky
movie before Felicia Rashad is so good
in this movie it's a sin she's not in
more of it what a finish
Victory's to the winner by split
decision and still beyond afraid so it's
just the end of rocky and rocky balboa
exciting ending and all but something a
little different wouldn't it killed
anyone you would have been somebody's
ring you don't have to call me bye
Felicia
what was his name do you care named fish
and matter what his name was he's dead
mom just career the same for me what are
you gonna do I wanna dance
Pennsylvania sorry about there John this
Johnny listen John it's a no Gretchen
stop trying to make fetch happen it's
not going to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe Creek will call me dude I'll call
you I'll call you want nobody calls me
chicken oh you just saw Rocky
[Music]